SPEAKER: All right.
Well, it's a great
pleasure to introduce
Bob Datta from very close by,
our neighbor, and actually
my neighbor and my friend.
So Bob got his PhD and his MD
from Harvard Medical School
in Michael Greenberg's lab.
He went on to a post-doc
with Richard Axel.
He subsequently joined
back, came back to Harvard
and is an associate professor
at Harvard Medical School.
And Bob has done amazing work
in many, many different domains,
so ranging from
understanding olfactory codes
to characterizing
quantitative behavior,
to basically looking
across from the
sensory to the behavioral
arc overall, and everything
in between.
And he's going to tell us I
think about some of the stuff
in between in
dopamine systems now.
So welcome, Bob.
And before, Bob, I let
you go on with your talk,
I think Lisa is here.
So I just want to acknowledge
her being present.
So hi, Lisa.
[APPLAUSE]
BOB DATTA: Can everyone hear me?
We're good?
Excellent.
So thank you, Ila, for
that kind introduction
and for the invitation
to come and speak.
And congratulations, both
to you and to everyone
here on the founding
of this ICoN Center.
I think it's the
right moment to think
about a sort of integrative
computational neuroscience.
I will say that I was really
excited by your first slide,
where you kind of described
trying to integrate data
across many levels,
going all the way down
to genes and molecules.
I think that's an
idea that many of us
have talked about for
a very, very long time
and haven't really
reduced to practice.
And it feels like we're having
a moment in neuroscience where
that's really possible.
So I'm excited for
this new ICoN Center,
and I look forward to
seeing the great work that
comes out of it.
So let's get going.
I have to stay on this
side, I think I do.
Oh, there we go.
Excellent.
So the behavior of animals
in the natural world, where
they're free to do what
they want, when they want,
is obviously remarkably complex.
And it's because
of this complexity
that to us, as humans, it often
appears that their behavior is
fundamentally inscrutable.
But of course, the ethologists
working 50 to 60 years ago
hypothesize that spontaneous
naturalistic behavior like this
actually has a ton of
underlying structure.
They believed that spontaneous
behavior is actually
composed out of a series
of behavioral modules,
brief three-dimensional,
stereotyped, repeated units
or motifs of action or movement
that are concatenated one
after the other in time to build
complex behavioral sequences
and which are organized
hierarchically in time, thereby
affording behavior a kind of
spatiotemporal organization
that's selected for by
evolution and allows animals
both to kind of deal
with the challenges
of their particular
ecological niche,
but also enables them
just enough flexibility
to adapt to changes in
context and contingency.
They also made an argument
that I think all of us
will find very intuitive,
which is that, if indeed there
is a kind of underlying
structure to behavior,
it must somehow arise
in the nervous system.
But despite the fact that
this sentence was written now
nearly 60 years ago, we
still, I would argue,
have only the most
superficial understanding
of how the brain composes
spontaneous behavior.
And by spontaneous behavior,
I mean the kind of behavior
that you and I and
almost every creature
spends most of our day doing,
the kind of behavior that
happens in the
absence of a task,
without obvious and
explicit reward,
sometimes without obvious
goals, the kind of behavior
that happens when
you're not confined
behaviourally or
psychologically or physically.
This question, how the brain
composes naturalistic behavior,
has really haunted my
lab for the last decade.
And so to begin to
address this question,
we've been building tools
that allow us to characterize
the underlying modular
basis for mouse
behavior in the laboratory.
And the idea is that if
we can begin to do that,
we can begin to test this
kind of ethological hypothesis
that behavior is
built out of parts.
The tool we've built and
we've been working on
is called motion sequencing,
or MoSeq for short.
We've published a bunch
on this technique,
and so I'm not
going to describe it
to you in any
great detail at all
because I want to show
you just the data.
But at a very high level, MoSeq
is an unsupervised machine
learning algorithm that,
based on the spatial temporal
structure of
behavioral data alone,
without any human
supervision or intervention,
is capable of discovering
an optimal set
of behavioral modules, or what
we call behavioral syllables,
out of which behavior
is composed in any given
experiment.
The behavioral data we tend
to feed motion sequencing
is 3D imaging of mice as
they explore simple arenas,
like this circular
open field over here.
And we obtain these 3D images
by placing depth cameras, which
we buy from Best Buy for
$100, over buckets that we
get for $5 from Home Depot.
And you can see the output
of one of these depth cameras
here.
Here heat mapped over
each pixel of the mouse
is its height at
any given position,
and you can very
much get the sense
that these cameras, even though
they're imperfect in many ways,
give you a rich representation
of the animals ongoing three
dimensional pose dynamics.
And again, we feed these 3D data
to the MoSeq algorithm, which
is a generative time series
model for behavior that
instantiates this ethological
hypothesis that behavior is
composed out of modules that
tumble, one after the other,
somewhat predictably in time.
And by fitting this model
through unsupervised
techniques, MoSeq discovers
that this kind of parts
list for behavior.
In a typical open
field experiment,
it discovers maybe 40 or 50
of these behavioral syllables,
which correspond to human
identifiable behaviors, things
like pauses, dives, and runs.
The average duration of each
one of these little behavioral
syllables is 300,
400, 500 milliseconds,
and so MoSeq teaches us about a
kind of sub-second architecture
that seems to be characteristic
of mouse behavior.
And we can synthesize
for any given experiment
the entire output of
motion sequencing into one
of these behavioral state maps.
Here, each node is a
behavioral syllable.
The diameter of each
one of these syllables
represents how often
within an experiment
that particular
syllable is used.
And the thickness of these
directional yellow arrows
indicates the
observed likelihood
of transition over time from one
behavioral syllable to the next
during the experiment.
And so I hope you can
tell just by inspection
that the behavior of
mice in the laboratory
is captured by MoSeq, just
like the behavior of mice out
in the real world
is characterized
by having an enormous
amount of structure.
And the question
we want to answer
is, where does the
structure come from?
How does the brain build this?
And that has got us thinking
about parts of the brain that
are involved in
building behavior
and specific corticobasal
ganglia loops,
and in particular the input
nucleus to the basal ganglia.
That's the part of
the brain here in blue
called the striatum because
of its well known roles
both in action selection
and in motor control, which,
of course, are going
to be functions
that are critical to composing
spontaneous naturalistic
behavior.
We've focused on a specific
subregion of the striatum,
a part of the striatum called
the dorsolateral striatum.
That's for a couple of reasons.
First, Dorsolateral
Striatum, or DLS,
gets inputs from
proprioceptive motor cortices,
suggesting the dorsolateral
striatum has access
to the kind of information you'd
want if you wanted to organize
your 3D post dynamics, but
also because work by others,
in particular Kent
Berridge, has suggested
that during simple spontaneous
behaviors, like grooming,
the dorsolateral striatum
might play an important role
kind of in organizing
those behaviors.
And so for all those
reasons, we wanted
to test the hypothesis
that maybe the DLS contains
within it neural correlates
for behavioral syllables,
behavioral grammar, the
sequence in which syllables
are expressed, or both.
So to address this
question, we have
rendered, together
with our collaborators,
motion sequencing
compatible with all forms
of neural recording.
And so now we can use MoSeq
as a general purpose platform
for querying brain
behavior relationships
during spontaneous behaviors.
So let me show you an
example of us doing this.
That's shown here.
So here, on the
upper left, is going
to be a mouse running around
in one of these buckets.
This is obviously 3D image.
Here we're going to
extract the movie, the 3D
movie of the mouse.
We're going to align it so
its nose is to the right
and its tail is to the left,
and we're going to center
it in this image.
You can tell that this
mouse is wearing a hat out
of which is coming
a cable, and that's
because we've been
planted in miniscope
within its
dorsolateral striatum.
And you can see what the
shape is visualizing here.
Here you're looking
at calcium transients
and individual spiny
projection neurons
in dorsolateral striatum.
And here in the center, we can
line these two data streams up.
Here on the bottom,
we're looking
at calcium transients and
individual spiny projection
neurons in DLS.
And up above is our
post hoc identification
of each behavioral
syllable as is expressed.
Sorry.
I'm a little bit under the
weather, so I just want to--
perfect.
And so what you can see,
even just by inspection,
is that there seems to be
some interesting relationships
between population level
activity in these neurons
and the behavior of the animals
express as they freely behave.
It's as if, as animals
switch from one
behavioral syllable
to the next, there's
a switching in the ensembles of
neurons that are activated such
that a new ensemble
of neurons is
kind of dialed in as
the animal switches
from one behavioral
syllable to the next.
And if we formally
analyze the data,
that's exactly what
seems to be true.
And indeed, if we look at
the ensembles themselves,
it turns out we can
use the identity
of each syllable-specific
neural ensemble
to make accurate predictions
about the specific 3D
behavior the animal's expressing
it at any given moment in time.
In other words, we
can kind of look down
at the animal's brain,
and I can tell you
which syllable it's expressing
on a moment by moment basis.
In addition, this neural data
contains within an information
about the specific
sequence context in which
each syllable is expressed.
And if we lesion the
dorsolateral striatum,
animals continue to
appropriately express
behavioral syllables from
a kinematic perspective.
But their ordering
is totally incorrect,
preventing them
from generating kind
of adaptive
sensory-driven behaviors.
And so what this tells
us is that, indeed,
the dorsolateral
striatum seems like it's
an important place
for organizing
spontaneous
behavioral sequences,
but it fails to tell us
some of the answers to some
of the key kind of remaining
questions about where
this structure comes from.
For example, why are
some behavioral syllables
used more than others?
Why do some behavioral
syllables, like this one, tend
to participate in highly
deterministic, very predictable
behavioral sequences, going
from here to here to here,
whereas other
behavioral syllables
tend to be connected to a bunch
of other behavioral syllables
more probabilistically
or randomly,
seemingly participating
in behavioral sequences
kind of more willy-nilly?
Where does all that
structure come from?
And so thinking
about that problem
got us thinking about the major
neuromodulator that influences
the striatum, and that
is, of course, dopamine,
which is well known to
influence both population level
activity in medium spiny
neurons in the striatum
and to be capable of inducing
plasticity in those very
same neurons, which is why
dopamine has been implicated
in a large number of different
contexts as a teaching signal.
The dopamine that talks
to dorsolateral striatum
largely arises from neurons
that live in the midbrain,
in substantia nigra pars
compacta, as shown here.
And there's reasonable reason
to believe that dopamine
might play an important
role in organizing
spontaneous behavior.
And we know that from
thinking just about what
the behaviors that are
changed in patients
with Parkinson's disease.
Those patients have difficulties
in initiating new movements,
in invigorating their
movements, and in appropriately
sequencing their movements.
That being said,
we actually know
very little about
the role of dopamine
during spontaneous
behavior in animal models.
There's basically
two lines of thought
about what dopamine might
be doing in animal models.
The first comes from work of
folks like Rui Costa and Dan
Dombeck, who have observed that,
as animals are stopped and then
generate a new
movement, there tends
to be a little
flicker in dopamine,
suggesting that maybe these
dopamine flickers that
are associated with movement
initiation are causal.
And indeed, if you
kind of optogenetically
induce a flood of
dopamine in the striatum,
animals will begin
a new movement.
There's another kind of
non-mutually exclusive set
of ideas coming
from Henry In's lab
that maybe dopamine dynamics
are actually quite continuous,
and the continuous
variation in dopamine
actually specifies the animal's
ongoing movement kinematics.
But again, as I've
mentioned, there's
actually hasn't been that many
careful kind of recordings
of dopamine as animals are
just spontaneously behaving
in any context.
So the degree to which either
of these is a general rule
remains a little
bit of a mystery.
What is true and what we know a
lot about from 40 years of work
is something that I've
already mentioned,
which is that dopamine plays
this key role as a teaching
signal and is capable of shaping
animals' future behaviors
in order to assist animals
in maximizing their ability
to obtain rewards.
But it's hard to think about
the kind of role dopamine
might play as a teaching
signal, helping animals
who obtain reward, in a
context like the open field
that I showed you, where
an animal is running around
in the dark, with no task, no
goals, and certainly no reward.
And so most of our
attention has been
focused on trying to
understand whether or not
dopamine during
spontaneous behavior
relates to initiation
or kinematics.
So we began thinking
about this, and we
decided to do a very simple
experiment, which is just
to repeat the experiment
I showed you before,
but now to record dopamine
transients specifically
in dorsolateral
striatum, through the use
of the dopamine reporter dLight.
And so here, we're
doing fiber photometry.
You can see the mouse running
around in the bucket over here.
And here you're looking
at dopamine transients,
as reported by dLight,
locked to syllables,
which are being
identified post hoc.
And what you can see
just by inspection
is that there are far too
many dopamine transients
to be explained by
movement initiation alone.
In addition, if we do a
ton of math, which we did,
we have a very difficult
time identifying
any kinematic
parameters that seem
to be encoded by these
dopamine fluctuations,
with one exception.
And that exception is velocity.
So what's interesting is that if
we bend the dopamine transients
at a relatively
short time scales,
at timescales of
5 to 10 seconds,
we actually see a
negative correlation
between the amplitude
or number of dopamine
transients the animal's
experiencing and its speed.
In other words, if there's
a burst of dopamine
during spontaneous
behavior, animals actually
tend to slow down.
And that kind of weird
counterintuitive result
is something that had been
observed by others in the field
before.
But what's interesting
is that if we've
been the data over longer
and longer time scales,
this relationship
actually seems to invert.
And now we have the kind
of comfortable positive
correlation between dopamine
and movement that all of us
were taught kind of in our
neuroscience classes, where
dopamine is thought to kind of
broadly invigorate or enable
in some way the animal's
ability to generate movement.
OK.
What about movement
initiation per se?
So this is what we see if we
look at movement initiations.
The x-axis here is time.
Time 0 is the moment at
which the animal generates
a new movement
after being still,
and indeed we can see
a nice little dopamine
flicker, as has been observed
in the past, associated
with the initiation of
a brand new movement.
But the amplitude
of this flicker
is much smaller
than the amplitudes
we observe if we
actually tee off
this data on all
behavioral transitions.
So here, time 0 is
actually the transition
from any syllable into
any other syllable,
so the animal is
moving here and it's
moving here, just that the
movements are different.
And what you can see are these
nice, large amplitude changes
in dopamine that
systematically reflect
when animals switch
from expressing
one behavioral
syllable to the next.
It's as if the dopamine kind of
exhausts itself as the animal
ends one syllable,
and then there's
this large upsurge in
dopamine as animals
enter into and begin to
express the very next syllable.
So this is what
we see on average.
We see this large systematic
fluctuation in dopamine
across all syllable transitions.
This isn't actually
what we see if we
look at individual syllables.
If we look at
individual syllables,
we see a lot of variation
in the dopamine amplitudes
that are, on average, associated
with any given syllable.
So here, we're identifying 40
different behavioral syllables
in this experiment.
And if we just look at this very
top behavioral syllable, which
turns out to be a rear, when
animals begin to express
this rear, dopamine
kind of quickly ramps up
to this very high amplitude and
then characteristically falls.
In contrast, if you
look at this syllable
down here at the bottom,
this turns out to be a pause.
When animals express a
pause, their dopamine
tends to be pretty low.
Then slowly during the
expression of the pause,
it ramps up.
And if we look at any
one of these syllables,
we'll see associated with
it a characteristic dopamine
waveform.
Now, this might
give you the idea
that we should be able
to use these waveforms
or their amplitudes to predict
which behavioral syllable
the animal's expressing
at any moment in time,
in much the same
way, as I told you,
that if we look at actual neural
activity and spiny projection
neurons, I can make an accurate
predictions about which 3D
behavior animals are expressing.
So if we try to
play that same trick
with these dopamine
transients, it
turns out we can't
make predictions.
I can't tell you which behavior
the animal's expressing
on a moment-by-moment
basis based
upon the dopamine
waveform that's
associated with that behavior.
And the reason why
becomes obvious
if we just look at
different instances
of this particular
behavioral syllable.
What we find is that there's
a huge amount of variability
in terms of the amplitude and
waveform in dopamine associated
with any given behavior.
Yes, indeed, on some
instances of this rear,
you see this kind of high
amplitude dopamine transient.
But on many instances,
you actually
see dopamine going in
the opposite direction.
And that holds true for all
of the behavioral syllables.
And so we can't
make predictions on
an instance-by-instance
basis of which syllable's
being expressed based upon
the dopamine waveform.
And this is broadly consistent
with my previous claim
that it does not
appear that dopamine
is encoding the kinematics
of the animal's movement.
Here are four separate examples
of the animal generating
the same rear, up behavior.
And yet, in all
four of these cases,
there's a different
dopamine waveform
that's associated with it.
So these dopamine waveforms
can't be encoding kinematics.
So now we're in this
kind of weird situation.
It's clear there's a
strong temporal correlation
between dopamine
kind of flickering
as the animals switch from
one syllable to the next
during spontaneous
behavior, but it's unclear
what these flickers
mean to the animal.
They certainly don't
encode kinematics
and they don't encode the
ongoing behavioral syllable.
So in order to kind of
clarify our own thinking,
we did a simple
calibration experiment.
So all we did was we
took some chocolate chips
and we just threw
them into the bucket.
And then we measured
dopamine transients
as animals consumed these
delicious and surprising and
rewarding treats.
And what we observed is that
the dopamine fluctuations that
were elicited when
the animals consumed
these surprising rewards, which
clearly in a different context
were capable of shaping
the animal's behavior,
were of roughly the same
amplitude as the fluctuations
that we were observing
in dorsolateral striatum
during spontaneous behavior.
And that suggested to us a
really surprising possibility.
Maybe these dopamine
fluctuations
aren't actually controlling
the animal's movements
in the moment.
Maybe they're
instead controlling
the animal's movements
in the future
by reinforcing in some way
the syllables with which they
are associated on any
given syllable instance.
If that is true, you would
make a very simple and basic
prediction, which is that those
syllables that are associated
with the most dopamine on
average during the experiment
are precisely those
syllables that
should be used the most on
average during the experiment.
And in fact, as you can see
here on the left, that's true.
The x-axis here is
dopamine, the y-axis
here is how often
the syllable's used.
Each dot here is a
syllable-mouse pair,
and indeed we see this
nice positive correlation,
revealing that those syllables
that are used the most
are those that on average
are associated with the most
dopamine.
And what's super interesting
is that this relationship
between dopamine
and syllable usage
holds true on a
moment-to-moment basis.
So if the animal's just
kind of generating behavior
and are a particular
instance of a syllable--
say that rear I
showed you-- there's
a high amplitude
dopamine transient, then
that particular rear is
going to be used more
for about the next 3 minutes, as
shown here by this orange line.
And if that very same rear
on some different instance
is associated with a relatively
low dopamine transient, then
over the next 3 minutes,
that specific syllable
will be used less.
Now, dopamine, of
course, is not just
important to reinforcement.
It's important to
action selection
in a whole variety of different
contexts that has been shown.
And so we wondered
whether or not
these dopamine transients
that were associated
with individual
syllables played any role
in determining the types of
sequences that syllables were
embedded in.
And so we just asked when, on
average, were those syllables
that were associated with
high levels of dopamine,
did they tend to be embedded
in more predictable sequences
or more random sequences?
And it turns out,
as you can see here,
that there's a nice positive
correlation between how
much dopamine on
average is associated
with a syllable
and the variability
of the behavioral choices
that animals would make
in the future,
such that syllables
associated with
high dopamine tend
to be embedded in more
variable behavioral sequences
and syllables that are
associated with low dopamine
tend to be expressed as part
of more predictable, less
variable, less
entropic sequences.
And again, this effect
seems to hold true
on a moment-by-moment basis.
If you're expressing
that rearing syllable
I was mentioning to you before
and you happen to be associated
with a high amplitude dopamine
peak, the next two, three,
or four behavioral
choices you make
tend to be more variable ones.
You tend to make a kind of more
unusual next behavioral choice,
as shown here by
this orange line.
And conversely,
if that same rear
is associated with relatively
low levels of dopamine,
the next thing you do tends
to be more predictable,
kind of more ho hum.
So now I've described to
you three things that appear
to be correlated with dopamine.
Those three things are
the animal's velocity,
the usage of individual
syllables on timescales
of minutes, and
behavioral variability
in terms of sequence
variability evolving
on timescales of seconds.
And we've built
encoding and decoding
models that kind of validate
all the correlations
that I've just described.
I'm not going to show
you any of those models.
Instead, I want to
turn to our attempt
to do a causal experiment.
What we wanted to do was to
somehow manipulate dopamine
specifically during the
expression of a given syllable
to ask whether that manipulation
would affect velocity, usage,
or variability.
So in order to do this,
we've taken advantage
of the magic of deep learning,
which allows us now to render
emotion sequencing closed loop.
So now we can look
down at animals freely
behaving and just running
around in a bucket,
and I can tell you
with about a 50
millisecond latency or so which
specific behavioral syllable
the animal's expressing
at any moment in time.
And based upon which
syllable it's expressing,
I can pick out a syllable
I want to manipulate
and I can send out an
optogenetic trigger.
And here we're going to use
those optogenetic triggers
to specifically cause dopamine
release in dopaminergic axons
that live within the
dorsolateral striatum itself.
So it's a very spatially
localized manipulation
of dopamine.
And here we're going to do
a kind of unusual thing.
We're going to calibrate our
optogenetic manipulation such
that the amplitude of dopamine
release that we observe out
here roughly matches
the amplitude
of dopamine transients that we
observe when animals are just
spontaneously behaving.
And practically,
what this means is
that we're giving a single
200-millisecond long continuous
wave pulse of light at
extraordinarily low powers.
And what that in turn means
is that this dopamine--
this kind of optogenetic
dopaminergic manipulation we're
making, which is
spatially localized,
is far more subtle in
general than the sorts
of dopaminergic
manipulations people
have made to implicate
dopamine in behavior.
And so it stood to
reason and we anticipated
that this kind of manipulation
should not change the animal's
behavior at all.
And indeed, if we measure
kinematic parameters,
either within a given syllable
or throughout the experiment,
we see that these kinds of
calibrated manipulations
in which we're manipulating
dopamine at the same scale
as dopamine is
naturally fluctuating
have essentially no
consequence on the animal's
ongoing movements.
These dopamine transients
that we're inducing
don't initiate new movements.
They don't change the
kinematics of syllables.
They don't change the animal
speed or force it to turn.
In other words,
these results suggest
that these natural
fluctuations in dopamine
that accompany
spontaneous behavior
are almost certainly
not causal, at least
in dorsolateral striatum,
for influencing the animal's
ongoing kinematics.
And we know this isn't just an
artifact of our optogenetics
not working because if we
just turn the light on now
for 2 seconds instead
of 200 milliseconds, now
we see the usual and
expected dramatic changes
in the animal's movement
in this other context.
So it looks like these
spontaneous fluctuations
aren't changing the
animal's ongoing kinematics.
What about how often
syllables are used?
So here we see
something very dramatic.
So here we're going to
pick one syllable out
of maybe eight or nine
that we've specifically
targeted for optogenetic
pairing and reinforcement,
here looking at some
pre-stimulation data
just to look at
baseline expression
of this particular syllable,
which is the rearing syllable.
I'm showing it to
you here in green.
And what see is that
nearly immediately,
as soon as we turn on
the light and begin
to pair the expression
of that rearing
syllable with dopamine,
within two or three pulses,
the animal recognizes
that there's
some sort of relationship
between this very
subtle optogenetic
manipulation we're making
and the generation of that
particular egocentric behavior.
And it begins nearly immediately
to upregulate the expression
of that targeted behavior.
It does it during
the first session.
We give it a little
bit of a break.
It does it again during
a second session.
And we know that this
isn't just dopamine
causing the upregulation
of the targeted behavior,
but instead it
reflects learning.
And we know that because
the latency for the animal
to express the targeted
syllable on the second session
is shorter than on
the first session.
And importantly, if
we turn the light off,
we see this kind of
persistent expression
of the targeted
behavioral syllable,
even in the absence of this
optogenetic manipulation,
consistent with
the animal having
learned an association
between dopamine
and this particular
behavior, again
consistent with reinforcement.
And I just want
to mention what I
think is kind of amazing here,
which is that, of course,
while we're doing this, the
animal is just running around
in a dark, empty bucket,
with no sensory cues
from the outside world at all.
So the only way the animal has
to know that it's generating
the targeted
behavioral syllable is
through [INAUDIBLE]
copies and proprioception,
but that is sufficient
for the animal
to understand its own behavior
and to cause this kind
of targeted upregulation.
What about behavioral
variability?
We can look at trials in
which we add a little dopamine
and compare the animal's
subsequent behavioral decisions
to what we observed
on those trials.
And we didn't add
a little dopamine.
What we see is consistent
with what I showed you
in the endogenous data, which
is that on those trials in which
we add a little bit
of extra dopamine
to a given behavioral syllable,
the very next behavior
the animal generates tends to be
a less likely or more variable
behavioral choice, whereas on
those [INAUDIBLE] trials where
we don't do that,
the animal tends
to do more predictable things.
And so it's clear from
what I've told you
that these kind of spontaneous
dopamine fluctuations
don't seem to be
influencing kinematics,
but instead seem to be
shaping the ongoing structure
of behavior, both by
influencing behavioral choices
in the near future, and I
think, most importantly,
by reinforcing over
time scales of minutes
the usage of associated
behavioral syllables.
And this suggests that maybe
these spontaneous dopamine
fluctuations that
we're observing
are acting as a kind of
continuous teaching signal
to sculpt the
architecture of behavior.
So we wanted to kind
of query that formally.
And so to do that, we've
built a simple, very simple
reinforcing learning model,
reinforcement learning model,
in which we use actual data,
actual dopamine syllable
associations, to train a
reinforcement learning agent.
And then we ask whether or not
the behavioral choices that
are made by this trained
reinforcement learning agent
match up with kind
of held out observed
behavioral choices that
are made by real-life mice.
And if, in fact,
they match up, it
would suggest that,
in fact, dopamine
is acting as a kind
of teaching signal.
So here, just to quickly
explain how the model works,
the state that the model is
in represents the syllable
the animal's expressing
at any moment in time.
The action is the animal's
choice of its next syllable.
Here we, of course, substitute
the traditional reward signal
for the dopamine that's
associated with any given
syllable.
And we use simple
cue learning rules
to update a cue
table, which here
is equivalent to a
transition matrix that
governs how any
syllable transitions
into any other syllable.
You'll notice here
we're only going
to focus on transitions
amongst the top 10 syllables.
That's because we're
a little data limited.
And you'll notice
also that there's
some syllable transitions
we don't consider,
and that's because these are
syllable transitions that don't
exist in the empirical data.
That said, we initialize this
transition matrix uniformly,
and then we just kind of train
a reinforcement learning agent
using simple cue learning rules.
And we can learn a transition
matrix that effectively
reflects the behavioral choices
this reinforcement learning
agent would make if it were able
to behave in the real world,
and then we can compare
this high-dimensional--
this 100-dimensional transition
matrix to an actual transition
matrix from held out data.
And what's remarkable
is that we capture
a huge amount of the
behavioral variation that's
observed in real-life
data when we just
train an RL agent using these
syllable-associated dopamine
transients.
And that really argues both
that continuous variation
in dopamine might be acting
as a teaching signal,
and that those signals might
be interpreted by animals
as reward-like signals,
On this last data
slide, I just want
to mention that
everything that I've
shown you here is specific
to dorsolateral striatum.
If we go ahead and repeat
the exact experiments
I've been describing to
you dorsomedial striatum,
we no longer see
the correlations
between dopamine and behavior
that I described to you before.
And when we try to
optogenetically stimulate
dorsomedial striatum,
now we can no longer
reinforce individual
behavioral syllables.
So to sum up, I've
described to you
at a kind of very high-level
motion sequencing, which
allows us to atomize behavior
into components, thereby
revealing this
kind of underlying
structure to behavior.
I've told you that it seems
like dorsolateral striatum plays
an important role in assembling
the behavioral sequences that
are captured by this
behavioral state map,
and that dopamine seems to play
an essential role in affording
this behavioral state
map its structure.
It does so not through
controlling the animal's
kinematics on a
moment-to-moment basis, which
is, I think, the kind
of naive, [INAUDIBLE]
prediction you would
have made, but instead,
in this kind of
very surprising way,
by acting as a teaching signal
to shape the future usage
and sequencing of
behavioral elements
during spontaneous behavior.
And what's really gratifying
about this is that, of course,
this means that the
role that dopamine
is playing during
spontaneous behavior
is analogous to the kind
of role that dopamine
has been well
characterized as playing
during much more
structured tasks
when animals have rewards.
It looks like the very
same kind of circuits
and in fact, the very
same computations
that support kind of
reward-based, goal-oriented
learning seem to come into play
during spontaneous behavior,
suggesting a kind of unitary
function for dopamine
in controlling the overall
architecture of behavior
in multiple circumstances.
And the key remaining
question is, of course, why
does dopamine vary?
What's controlling the
variation in dopamine,
thereby structuring behavior?
That's a problem
for another day.
And so with that
I'll just mention
that the work that
I've showed you today
was largely done by Jeff
Markowitz, who just started
his own lab of Georgia Tech,
along with two great graduate
students, Wen
Gillis and Maya Jay.
And all this work is part
of a broad collaboration
I have with Bernardo Sabatini,
Scott Linderman, and now
Uchida.
Thanks for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: We have a few
minutes for questions.
AUDIENCE: When you showed
[INAUDIBLE] syllable
[INAUDIBLE].
BOB DATTA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was
doing a [INAUDIBLE]
where they come from
and [INAUDIBLE]..
BOB DATTA: That's
a good question.
So the reason why we built
these encoding and decoding
models was to get a
sense of-- there's
going to be some correlation
amongst all of them.
The correlations
are pretty weak.
But we wanted to get a sense of,
if we were to build an encoding
model, for example, or
a decoding model, what's
the relative weight afforded
to each one of these kind
of behavioral features, if
you wanted to, for example,
predict the fluctuations
in dopamine?
So it turns out that each
one of these three things
seems to play a different and
complementary role in kind
of recovering the
dopamine transients.
So all three seem to matter.
And what's interesting
is that if you
look at the time scales at which
the beta parameters evolve,
it turns out that velocity
is important at very, very
short time scales along with
sequence variability, which
is exactly what I showed
you in the correlations.
And usage tends to be
important over much longer time
scales, which is exactly
what I showed you.
Usage seems to be
reinforced for minutes,
whereas variability
and velocity seem
to be important over seconds.
And actually, the models
capture those temporal dynamics
and demonstrate
that it looks like,
if you wanted to predict
dopamine, you'd need all three
of these different
behavioral features
to make accurate predictions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That was amazing
how you pin down
these relationships between
dopamine and the syllables.
I'm wondering,
though, is this kind
of dopamine noise, or
reward noise that's
happening in these situations
where the animal is just
walking around and
you have these kind
of micro unmotivated or
unexplained fluctuations
that have no purpose, and the
animal's behavior is modulated
by it but not in any
purposeful or good way?
BOB DATTA: Yeah.
So in my discussion, which--
there are many
possibilities for where
these dopamine
fluctuations arise.
And in fact, David
Kleinfeld has recently
published a paper in which
essentially stochastic dopamine
fluctuations in the cortex,
over much longer time
scales that I'm
showing you here--
these are subsecond
fluctuations.
His fluctuations are
over many minutes.
But high-amplitude dopamine
fluctuations in the cortex
are seemingly appropriated,
these random fluctuations
are seemingly
appropriated as kind
of windows of learning that
animals can take advantage
of that shape behavior in
this kind of accidental way.
We think that this
is not accidental
and we have ideas about
where these fluctuations are
coming from.
And the reason we think it's
not accidental is because--
I think I kind of didn't
have time to elaborate on,
but which, I think,
when you think about it,
is pretty obvious, is when
you throw a mouse in a bucket,
actually, it has
characteristic and stereotyped
behavioral dynamics that
evolve in a really reliable way
across animals, across time.
So when animals first
get into the bucket,
they're in this kind
of exploration mode
and they kind of are in this
like less exploratory mode,
and then they're in this
kind of chill out mode.
And that's all very stereotyped.
So the fact that
behavior itself has
very stereotyped
temporal dynamics
is difficult to
reconcile between--
and if dopamine is
in fact, reinforcing,
it's difficult to
reconcile those two things.
And so we think it's not noise.
I mean, formally, it could be.
It's choice number 3 in our
discussion of possibilities.
But I think it's likely
to be something--
we think it's likely to
be the output of some sort
of computation that's actually
shaping the animal's behavior.
And if you'd like
me to speculate
on what I think that
computation is, I'd be glad to.
AUDIENCE: I was intrigued
by your observations
of dopamine dips around the
transition points of syllables.
And it sort of aligned with a
question that I generally have,
which is that it seems like
you're treating dopamine
as a sort of prospective
signal, rather than
looking at it as sort of
a retrospective signal.
And I'm wondering
if you've looked
at explicitly the stoppage
of syllables associated
with the dip, since one syllable
stops before another begins,
and sort of related
to that, if you,
with your optogenetic
stimulation, if you
look at what's happening
before your stimulation.
I realize you're
doing this in closed
loop with a specific
syllable, so it makes sense
that one is reinforced.
But I guess I'm wondering
about your framework
and thinking about it
sort of prospectively
rather than retrospectively.
BOB DATTA: So you
might imagine that
either just in the
endogenous data when
we look at correlations,
or in the optogenetic data,
there might be some temporal
slop, that maybe when
I reinforce a syllable,
it doesn't just
reinforce that
syllable, but you might
expect that it would
reinforce the behavior that
led to that syllable
and the syllable
before, retrospectively.
Or you might expect
that it could maybe
be a teaching signal in the
kind of anterior direction.
So we've done all of the sorts
of things you'd want us to do.
We've taken the dopamine
signals and lagged them out,
forward and backwards,
to see whether or not
the correlations still hold.
In all of our models, we do
that as routinely as a control.
So it turns out that the
reinforcement that we're
predicting based upon an
endogenous dopamine fluctuation
really seems like
it's temporally
associated with the syllable
that it's attached to.
There is a little
bit of slop, maybe.
The amount of
reinforcement goes down
by a factor of a log to the two
temporally adjacent syllables,
and that's it.
We can do the same thing in the
reinforcement learning model.
I showed you this beautiful
transition matrix.
If we just shift over the
relationship between behavior
and dopamine by one
syllable, that relationship
goes to almost nothing.
So it really is quite
precise, actually,
which is a little bit
surprising and interesting.
I'll say that we've built a
model in which a prediction you
might make is that those
syllables that on average are
associated with
the most dopamine
should be those syllables
that show the greatest
degree of reinforcement, if our
exogenous optogenetics is kind
of being added to the
endogenous fluctuations.
That prediction turns out
to be true, again, kind
of centering our
attention on the syllable
that we're actually targeting.
But you're right.
There is some slop
in both directions.
There's a little bit
of retrospective slop,
a little bit of
prospective slop.
I also mentioned-- sorry,
sometimes I get to talk.
I'll also mention one
thing about this, which
I think is really interesting.
So the duration distribution
of the syllables
has a mean that's 400
or 500 milliseconds,
but the actual
implementation of syllables
is often much longer than that.
And what that means is that
we're shutting the light off
and the dopamine
transient that we induce
is off nearly always before
the syllable is completed.
And yet syllables stay intact.
So if behavior were truly fully
continuous and not discretized
in any way, you might imagine
that we would be reinforcing
just the front half of
each syllable, or just
the part of the
syllable that was
associated with our
optogenetic manipulation.
But actually, that's not true.
Syllable durations
don't change at all
when we do this optogenetic
manipulation, only
usages change.
And that suggests this
kind of intriguing idea
that maybe there's something
discrete about behavior
at this time scale, which is
very consistent with the things
that you were talking
about earlier today, which
I love that work about
autocorrelation across cortex.
And I very much have been
thinking about the idea
that maybe those
kinds of time scales
are setting these
discrete time scales that
are used by the brain
to organize sensation
and action into little bundles
that make sense to the brain.
That's a speculative idea
we can talk about at dinner.
SPEAKER: Great.
Fantastic.
I'm sorry.
Let's do it at poster time
because it's poster session.
So please hold your questions
and bring them to Bob.
[APPLAUSE]